this video is sponsored by keems which
means we'll have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everybody it is time for another
gaming related q a i do q and a's about
like everything other than video games
uh on my second channel i'm also like a
month behind on that so i'll leave a
link to where you can check those out if
you want this is all for gaming and
we're gonna start on very positive news
i got a whole bunch of questions about
this and i'm sure i've addressed it
before but it's something that i'm
always happy to reiterate matty gal said
how have you felt about the reaction to
go to a ragnarok's trailer and what's it
like to work on a game like that if you
can talk about it um so i'm obviously
very selective in what i do talk about
in the interest of protecting the studio
there are a bunch of reasons for that
the biggest one is honestly just that i
don't want to say anything that'll ever
make a news headline which has happened
before the studio should get to dictate
when interviews go out or when news
happens pr should get to dictate that i
should not have any control over that
and so i try to just like respect
everybody else's schedules and and try
not to become news by accident they have
already been headlines santa monica
studio employee says never anything
particularly interesting but uh i'm just
aware that that can happen and um i
don't want to contribute to it however i
can answer what you've asked me here
which is uh how we felt about the
reaction to go to war ragnarok's trailer
um
it's so awesome i've actually not sat
down to watch reaction videos yet i
think i'll probably do that on friday i
might stream that on twitch because
that is extra cool and
so obviously this is the second trailer
this is an our first trailer and i think
what gets me about this one is that
people are excited and i just keep going
that's just the beginning you have no
idea and yeah at this point i'm just
really really really really excited for
people to play it i can't wait i can't
wait to
you know see the fan reactions to it and
watch streams and and just see how
people
react to certain story beats and
it's just you're in for a ride and i say
that as someone who still largely feels
like a bystander uh i did very little
work on this game i am in the credits
and
that is very very cool to have you know
done enough work to be in the credits
it's uh
it's i think the third aaa game that i
have a credit in
but definitely the one that i had the
biggest hand in and um yeah it's really
surreal
because
just the whole team at santa monica
studio i'm just so impressed all the
time it's nuts the people i get to work
with are so good at what they do on so
many levels that i've never experienced
at any other company before everyone is
so talented and hardworking and
i'm just blown away by the stuff that
that people come up with and the stuff
that i get to see and and seeing the
creativity on display but it's also yeah
i just i i can't wait for people to to
play the game and to experience it it's
it's i'm just like at the point where i
feel like i probably feel the same way
fans do or i'm like just let them have
it
but of course it doesn't work that way
so
yeah the reception has been absolutely
wonderful and so nice to watch you know
more on behalf of of the people i work
with and on behalf of me again who i
didn't do [ __ ] but i'm just really
excited and uh honored to be a part of
it i'm like glowing for the the last
couple of days about it just because the
hype has been so
awesome to witness so if you feel
positive about it please keep sharing it
it's so cool and people do notice they
do pay attention to that stuff um i
think it really means a lot so thank you
for asking i have felt amazingly about
the reaction to the trailer it has made
me more excited for everybody because
it gets so much cooler even in my
opinion and it still feels um like a
very surreal honor now we got that out
of the way my phenomenon said elana what
are your thoughts on emulation and video
games to be cool with the sega dreamcast
mini i think it's kind of complicated a
lot of emulation is piracy i don't
generally support piracy however when
some of these things can't be accessed
otherwise i will um be in the favor of
video game preservation if emulation is
the only way that you can actually
access something and you wouldn't be
able to play it otherwise i think i am
in favor of that and i wish there were a
system of preservation that some of
these companies uh could be more
supportive of so that it didn't have to
become
piracy like i don't think that the
user or the player is at fault if the
only way for them to play something is
to pirate it that is an accessibility
problem
that the publisher
should be addressing and you're kind of
like
forcing people's hand a little bit i
think not confident in everything that i
just said i feel like that's my take but
a lot of the time i don't have like a
solid opinion on something and i'm like
that's just where i feel right now if i
explored this thought further i may
change my mind so i don't use emulators
and i've never felt the need to maybe
there was once or twice that i used to
use one back in the day and i think that
they are a very good tool and i wish
they were supported i think is my
general reaction i wish that they would
be supported in a way that i guess
nintendo kind of supports emulation but
they charge so much for it i mean the
xbox backwards compatibility stuff is a
really good example of like that's you
are preventing people from needing to
emulate an xbox the original xbox
by providing that emulation yourself and
i think that that's awesome and that's
the direction that we should want it is
time to talk about keeps there's no
magic cure for boldness but you can
prevent hair loss from happening in the
first place the earlier you take action
the more hair you'll keep for those of
you who don't already know keeps is a
subscription service that helps men keep
their hair it is fda approved provider
recommended and i have several friends
people you've seen me make videos with
beautiful heads of hair who use keeps
and love it which is why i'm so
confident talking about it cubes offers
clinically proven treatments to combat
the symptoms of hair loss and treatments
are delivered straight to your door your
daily supply of treatment arrives every
three months at half the cost of a
pharmacy once you've taken action all
you need to do is track your progress
and get support along the way keeps
treatment plans come with a year of
unlimited doctor messaging all the
treatment plans are personalized and
doctor recommended and they're
affordable typically half the cost of
pharmacy prices so it's time to take
action because with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or pharmacy
they have a network of expert medical
providers prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality and whether
you're looking to prevent a hair loss
stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com alana pierce or click the
link in the description that's k-e-p-s
dot com slash alana calfoni blackwood
said question for the next video what's
your opinion on horror games not having
a category at game awards do you think
it's even necessary to have them now or
even an entire award show dedicated to
the horror genre similar to spike tv's
award shows back in the day well i've
never seen any spike tv awards show i
think that that's what the game awards
used to be but i am australian so it was
an american thing so i never even saw
the actual spike tv awards i think that
horror in general can be a very
difficult thing to classify we spoke
about this in a recent play watch listen
episode pretty extensively horror can
be subjective so like i would argue that
half of resident evil 8 is horror and
the other half is action so it goes into
the action category whereas like
i would say that a game like madison
is
clearly horror and i think because
that's the case for a lot of aaa games
which you know i talk about game awards
all the time and how they don't mean
anything and you shouldn't care and they
are not definitive it's just a bunch of
people's opinions and it's always going
to come down to whatever the most
popular thing is like this year i feel
like game of the year is almost
definitely going to be either god of war
ragnarok or ellen ring and the fact that
we all kind of knew that in january is
indicative of
how just meaningless the awards are
they are supposed to be a celebration of
video games not a clear true answer of
the game of the year is what i'm trying
to say and the games that that win are
nominated are always the most popular
the ones that the most people are able
to play
the ones that are advertised the most
just by virtue of it being a very big
jury it has to be whichever game is
played the most you can't vote on a game
you haven't played and you can't play
every game in the world it's impossible
so that means that the horror games that
are going to be selected for any
category are going to be the most triple
a ones that exist which generally is
going to lean into action there are
probably not enough aaa horror games for
the category to make enough sense um it
would otherwise and this is just me
hypothesizing uh i think it would
otherwise end up being full of indie
games a lot of people haven't heard of
they mentioned madison a lot of people
haven't heard of madison so while
survival horror is my favorite genre of
video game and if i
impart anything onto any of the games
that i work on it is definitely a little
bit of horror i do it so much i'm always
like but what if it was spooky
i just can't help myself i'm sure i'll
end up working um like full time on a
survival horror somewhere someday it's
just the world that draws me um but yeah
i think it's probably uh an unappealing
genre to a lot of people and there just
aren't enough aaa horror games to to
really hold it i think it would be cool
to have that category
i also just again i just don't put a lot
of stock in these award shows
it is what it is it is what it is it'd
be cool to have your own um
you know video game horror awards i
think there are a lot of them for movies
and tv shows because horror games sorry
horror movies and tv shows always get
snubbed at the award shows the fact that
midnight mass didn't get a bunch of
nominations so clearly genre related
that show is brilliant in so many ways
but it didn't get tb nominations
because it's horror genre and so people
just don't even watch it
uh but i don't know that you get a lot
of viewership for that unfortunately
jonathan forsyth asked
someone who would love to step their
foot into the gaming industry where do
you think the best place to start is
uh it depends on
what you are good at i
have been good at writing since i was a
child i did extension english as a kid
so i was doing like i think two grades
above or one grade above
i went to a gifted kids writer's camp
and and um i was top one percent in the
country for writing at one point
as a kid and then i started writing at
university and then i went on to write
about video games and now i write video
games for me it's a very easy path for a
lot of other people you just kind of
have to figure out
what your equivalent of that is what's
the thing you've always been really good
at because the games industry has so
many roles
so many roles artists programmers
designers you can do accounting you can
do engineering you can do marketing you
can do pr there are so many facets of
the games industry and it's a huge
industry and it's only getting bigger so
it's it's not like possible i don't
think to just be like i want to work in
that industry and weasel your way in of
course it's very competitive so you have
to have a very competitive um resume
they get a thousand applicants a day
from people who don't have the right
experience that just get discarded i've
been part of the hiring process at a lot
of these big companies so you have to
have excelled in something other than
just liking video games the amount of uh
cover letters i've read that have just
been like i love video games we're like
of course you do
but that is not valuable to the team as
we all also love video games not uh not
a weak spot there so it's more about
like what skills do you have
independently of liking video games that
um
you can see a part in the games industry
and that is step one is figure out what
that is get the qualifications where
that thing is concerned and then you
start applying for jobs obviously
networking is super important but that's
my basic piece of advice a lot of people
think that they can review games just
because they have opinions on games but
that doesn't make a good game reviewer
skill set being able to write is very
important to be a game reviewer unless
you're making youtube content in which
case it would be video production and
hosting and video editing all things
that you can learn by yourself
so
yeah i think there's always an avenue
you just have to know
where you would serve the industry best
i guess and then just do everything you
can to to get there best of luck my
friend you've got this kev and like said
hey i love the video thank you what are
you missing from more recent video games
any specific
it wasn't even that long gamepl
you used to just put the cartridge in or
put the disc in and the thing would play
i can't believe that's just gone
and it's never coming back i mean there
are exceptions but for the most part we
now just accept that you have to install
something even when you buy a disk
version you usually have to install
something
i just
uh
remember when you didn't have to do that
yeah that's definitely the one that
stands out to me the most i feel like
there are so many games now and so many
retro style games like i
formally decided that doom 1993 is my
favorite game ever made i love it so
much
i often said deadly premonition but i
was like when i really sit down and
think about this it's doom and i could
say oh i miss doom i miss your boomer
shooter but
there are still so many of those being
made like dusk like bolt gun that's
about to come out so i don't think
there's like really
any missing mechanic or art style or
story element at all because there are
just so many games being made that
capitalize on retro aesthetics or styles
or gameplay
you just have to look for the specific
thing you're interested in but you have
to download all of them
yeah it kills me luna guzman said what
do you actually do are you writing story
law dialogue etc um i get asked this a
lot so i figured i would answer it even
though i've
kind of paraphrased that question um the
writers on my team uh write everything
we all write everything with the
exception of like there are things that
i'm better at writing and things that
i'm not good at writing not good at
writing romance so like if something
romantic existed i would pass on it i'd
be like hey probably this person is
better at writing this so they should
write that you just like play to the
team's strengths in case of my team we
all write everything
um and that is similar my experience of
every other game studio that i have been
involved in sometimes the game director
is still the person riding the box so
yeah knighthood said if you could write
the story for a sequel to any game which
game would it be
i don't really think about video game
writing this way um my thing is that i
always just want to work with a good
team
so i don't care what story i write i
just care about the people that i write
it with and about how the team works and
about learning from that team um that
said
a red dead redemption 3 would kill me
alrighty that is it for me today
everybody if you want to leave questions
for next month leave them in the
comments below
i will just pick through them next month
when i answer them
and like i said if you would like to ask
questions for the next personal q a i'll
leave a link in the description to where
you can do that i'll probably record
that over the weekend because i am very
behind on that thank you for watching
i'll see you guys next time